[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
observers chief lead writer sonia soder
in the daily telegraphs chief political
correspondent christopher hope they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages the guardian leads
with boris johnson admitting the nhs is
under huge pressure but is insisting
england can ride out its biggest ever
coveted wave
as hospitals struggle with the number of
patients the metro also quotes the prime
minister with a headline we can write it
out the times also focuses on boris
johnson's belief the uk can ride out the
current wave without needing any more
restrictions
this is the sun that's also their lead
the eye meanwhile
goes with the announcement that a
hundred thousand critical workers
involved in food transport and borders
are to be given daily tests
covered testing rules will be relaxed as
part of efforts to shorten isolation
periods and ease staffing shortages
reports the daily telegraph
and the financial times leads with the
rise of travel and leisure stocks with
investors growing more confident the
economic impact of omicron is waning
and we're joined tonight as i was saying
by sonia soda and christopher hope good
evening to you both thank you so much
for joining us
let's begin um with boris johnson's
press conference shall we five o'clock
this afternoon first thoughts sonia what
do you think
so i think this is the prime minister
sort of setting out a continuation of
his position which is that plan b is
enough so we're going to stick with plan
b it's going to get really really tough
for the nhs indeed we've already seen
several hospital trusts declare critical
incidents in recent days
um but that's the plan and that's what
we're going to stick with and i think
this was his opportunity to sort of um
put a put a mast in in the post and
there and and to say that
um
i think there's there's more data
there's more data that's come out in the
last two or three days and it's quite a
mixed picture so it really kind of
depicts how this is a very very
different wave
of covid from the waves that have come
before it so there are some really good
bits of news which is what the prime
minister wanted to focus on which is
that you know it is looking increasingly
certain that omicron in most people
as a milder form of illness
um but at the same time we are seeing
this uh very strong pressure on the nhs
and we've seen that um you know in
london in recent
days and weeks but now in the north
we're starting to see i think experts
are worried because hospitalization
rates are going up faster in the north
than they are
um
than they have been in london and also
there is this key issue around staffing
and the impact that staff absence is
because staff are self-isolating on the
nhs and indeed tonight we've seen in
manchester most hospitals across
manchester have said that they are
calling off all non-urgent um surgery
and treatment uh because uh capacity is
so so low so it's a different form of
wave omicron appears to be causing less
severe illness but we are still seeing
hospitalizations that's still putting a
huge amount of pressure on an nhs that
sort of had to deal with a decade of
underfunding it went into the pandemic
with a huge number of staff vacancies
and really sort of the crunch um that's
being applied on top of that is that
there's been a huge increase in waiting
lists over the last 18 months because of
the pressure that's covered has put on
the nhs so you've got a health system
that's trying to catch up at the same
time as deal with much greater pressure
than normal over the winter which is
really leading to this situation that
we're seeing at the moment
it was such an interesting day wasn't it
let's um have a look at the metro the
front page there
pm we can ride it out let's um bring
that up yeah there we go we can ride it
out christopher it was it was such an
interesting day because
the the
the day was spent reporting on these
trusts that were declaring critical
incidents and then we had this press
conference in which the pm was saying
it's okay plan b is working we're going
to stick to these restrictions yeah
i wouldn't say it was okay i mean he's
worried about it and we're only you know
everyone's worried about it he admitted
in his uh press conference at five
o'clock that part of the nhs would feel
overwhelmed
it was necessary to put the nhs on a war
footing in his quotes with more help
from the military um and everything with
sonia in her in her tour there the
issues in the nhs is correct but pm's
position is
look it's serious but we can get through
that um and we'll see later on how the
financial markets are reacting to that
optimism it looks like the pm
he may just pull this off and i think
that it takes a degree of bravery i
think to do nothing sometimes in
politics it's all very well being busy
and doing things because then you can
always say well i did something
and it didn't work to do nothing and
hope that until by that i mean to not
not to shut the uh communities down like
happened in scotland and wales to try
that and for that to work does take a
degree of bravery which he may get some
credit for
sonnet do you what do you think do you
think he will get credit um
for as christopher says his bravery and
doing nothing
i think it's uh far too early to tell
i think
if you look backwards at the pandemic
and i think this is the stuff that will
come out in the inquiry actually boris
johnson has done nothing too often so
he's definitely taken too much time to
introduce restrictions when there was an
unarguable case for them at previous
points in the pandemic and i think you
know we've seen thousands of avoidable
deaths out of that now what happened in
the last
month or so is quite different in the
sense that we saw some nations so
scotland wales northern ireland uh take
actions whereas the westminster
government did not and actually there
was a much greater degree of uncertainty
i think this time around
previous points in the pandemic and so
actually you can make a bigger case but
actually i think you know you can make
the case for taking the action that
scotland and wales did but you can also
make the case for taking no action as
christopher said so on on on this point
in the pandemic i think the jury is
still out but i think when the inquiry
comes to consider what's happened over
you know the length of time that we've
seen so far i think it's unarguable but
actually the prime minister has tended
towards taking far too little action too
late which has not only led to more
avoidable deaths but has actually
created bigger consequences for the
economy because when you actually
in an exponential pandemic it leads to
um
tougher action for longer which is
something that everyone wants to avoid
definitely arguable
that's definitely an arguable position
look at the vaccine uh roll out look at
the vaccines that they've procured look
at the booster program look at the fact
that he had the the pm released
restrictions in last summer in the uk
which has given a degree of heard
immunity yes he was late back at the
beginning of the of the entire pandemic
but i think i think that's pretty harsh
that's a guardian view an observer view
possibly of boris johnson that that the
inquiry may not adopt
um christopher let's look at your um
paper now
oh sorry go ahead sonia sorry go ahead
just repeat that
i think it's just an observer view i
think plenty of other scientific experts
i said and i think you know you can you
can maybe understand why the government
got it wrong back in march 2020 but it
was really around autumn 2020 where the
cabinet are having all those political
struggles about when to act that is
actually when i think the prime minister
is extremely culpable in acting too late
um not taking the advice of scientific
advisors and actually it led to i think
a tougher lockdown in in january to
march 2021
okay let's have a look at the daily
telegraph um christopher this is your
paper do you want to just talk us
through the front page here
yes this is all about the the
requirement to have these the these
covid tests and it's it is tackling the
staff absences which sonia talked about
there in in various nhs trusts and why
that's having a massive bearing on
whether people can have a normal
elective surgery so the idea here is
there are plans being drawn up by the by
the nhs and um
looking at whether pcr tests uh to those
with should only be given to those with
symptoms rather than those who are
asymptomatic around this might allow
around 40 of cases of people to return
to work more quickly they're looking
around the edges about whether they're
they're you i i know um
elsewhere they're looking at whether
they need to necessarily um have have
these lateral flow tests um in order to
get back in get to get back to work or
to or to find ways to
to um to double down on whether the
requirement to to justify a positive
natural flow test if someone is ill or
what thinks they have covered maybe
don't uh have a pcr test to check on
that there are all sorts of ways they're
trying to make these tests go further uh
for the next couple of weeks there'll be
a quite a bite on these tests according
to satijavid the health secretary and
here's one example
okay do you think um sonia do you think
that perhaps this is how
what we have to do in the next couple of
weeks really rethink
everything how we test how much how long
we isolate for and that comes from a new
understanding basically of what this
variant is doing
well i think you definitely have to
adapt your approach in terms of new data
coming out and i think actually this
sort of proposal which is to say you
know if you've not got symptoms and you
test positive and a lateral flow test
you can start the self-isolation clock
from that point rather than from when
you get your pcr test results um
obviously if you've got symptoms and
then you get a positive pcr two or three
days later you start the clock from when
the symptoms develop so that could
actually um sort of save people with ace
symptomatic covert kind of you know two
or three days and actually i think
that's quite a sensible thing to do i
think the other big debate we'll have um
coming up in two or three weeks
is um whether we should be reducing
self-isolation the self-isolation period
further it's already been reduced from
ten days to seven days for people who
get consecutive negative lateral flow
tests on day six and day seven
um some countries for example the us
the us sort of government authorities
there have gone further and reduced that
to a five-day self-isolation period now
our government has looked at that and in
the last sort of 24 hours 48 hours has
been clear that it doesn't think that
the evidence is strong enough yet it's
concerned that you would have people
going out on day six and seven um a
significant enough number of people who
are still infectious to sort of
outweigh the benefits of um you know
getting an extra couple of days off the
self-isolation period but i think that's
going to be a big debate coming up in
the next two or three weeks particularly
as more data comes out about that and
that is definitely something to to watch
out for
um let's have a look at the ft and
they're talking about travel and leisure
shares christopher you said we'll we'll
really see how the markets react
tomorrow um following that press
conference but we're already seeing here
a surge in travel and leisure shares
i often think we overlook the ft
sometimes on this kind of news when
we're so busy dealing with uh newspapers
that address the the vote of the
population this is a if it's a very
niche paper the ft but look at where the
money is going the money here is betting
that the omricon
turmoil is is nearly over you know the
the the the worst we're seeing the worst
now and these uh these uh investors are
betting on the future i think following
the money here looks like you know
travel stocks rising sharply this report
says um you know the the the these
the they may seem severe at the moment
but the financial markets are seeing the
end of it um and perhaps they're taking
a leave from boris johnson's optimism
and that's driving driving uh investors
into these areas which have had such a
hard time over the past two years don't
forget it's called kobit 19 because it
was discovered in 2019 and now it's 2022
and the main sector that's born the the
pressure on that in terms of financial
markets is hospitality travel and
leisure so if these shares are up maybe
just maybe
we're getting near the end of this
sonia very quickly as we're about to
hit a break what do you think the
economic threat fading
well i think we all have to hope that
the investor optimus is right um
uh i think certainly with omicron the
picture is looking more positive now
there's a little bit more certainty
around that even though there are these
huge pressures on the nhs then it was
sort of two or three weeks ago but i
guess the problem with this disease is
you just never know what nasty turn may
be around the corner and uh we don't
know what sort of variants there are but
but let's hope these investors are right
so i think we all want to see
uh the end of covet as soon as possible
absolutely fingers crossed okay we're
gonna take a quick break coming up
prince andrew waits to hear if the
lawsuit against him will proceed we'll
discuss that next
[Music]
hello again you're watching the press
preview with me now sonia sodium and
christopher hope there they are again
thank you both um let's start um sonia
will you kick us off with this guardian
story the latest hearing um in this
civil case against prince andrew
that's right and it's on the front page
of the guardian but several other papers
as well really big story this so
virginia dufrese who is one of jeffrey
epstein's victims is now suing in the
american civil courts or trying to see
uh prince andrew who she says alleges um
she was forced to have sex with when she
was still a child when she was 16 and
17.
now obviously these are cut these are
allegations that prince andrew
denies
but the thing that is working its way
through the american civil courts at the
moment is she settled with jeffrey
epstein her abuser
in a civil settlement and as part of
that settlement which got um exposed yes
it got published yesterday it was
previously been a private settlement
it became apparent that uh one of the
clauses that she'd signed was that
part of this settlement was that she
would not take a case against epstein's
associates now what that clause actually
means in the american civil courts is
very much up for debate but the key
thing that this hearing was focused on
today was
does this get prince andrew off the hook
from facing this lawsuit against him in
the american civil courts prince
andrew's lawyer says that it does
virginia due phrase lawyers say that it
absolutely does not now it's always very
hard to tell what the outcome is going
to be before the judge produces his aunt
his or her answer but in this case i
think some of the things the the some of
the things that the papers are reporting
on it are actually he seemed pretty
incredulous at some of the statements
from prince andrew's lawyer um uh that
this this did mean that that prince
andrew doesn't need to face a civil
lawsuit so we don't know yet exactly
whether this lawsuit will proceed if it
does it will be a huge deal for the
royal family um prince andrew
essentially facing being sued in the u.s
courts with these allegations of sexual
assault against him
but he his lawyer will be hoping uh that
that they are able to make use of these
clauses to to prevent that from
happening it's been so interesting um
listening to the arguments around what
looked like a very cut and dry contract
and let's move on christopher to your
story and page one in the telegraph just
talk us through the pros and cons of
cutting vat on energy bills
well there's been a big push here from
back bench mps led by on notorious side
led by craig mckinley to try and do
something to get ahead of this whole
cost of living crisis which we're just
on the cusp of which many in westminster
where i've been all day think is the big
issue of the first half of this year
because there are big increases going in
energy bills
notwithstanding the increased national
insurance um and uh and another os2 in
council tax and others so there's big
concerns here about this cost of living
crisis the tories on the torch i'd try
to urge the government to do something
to deal with it and yet again we'll go
back into this row this row this tension
at the top of government between boris
johnson who might be keener to do it
to to to cut taxes and maybe richie
sunac at the treasury who's less keen um
boss johnson here coming out saying well
cutting v80 that's five percent v80 on
energy bills would have a lot of people
who don't need it says boris johnson
doesn't rule out some degree of of
support here for low-income families
with big bills coming going going up
very shortly yeah but saying that it
wouldn't necessarily do it across the
board on the brexiteer side this could
be a
dividend christopher i've got to jump in
there sorry yeah wait and see um we're
going to take a break but you're with us
until just before midnight tonya and
christopher thank you